what up guys good morning so I'm gonna
be I'm taking part in a bishop gun music
video and you know that that band has a
special place in my heart and there you
are they are swaggy breath they swag it
and so I'm excited I already love the
song that I'm being in so you know I'm
just hopeful today that I can you know
just service their music as well as I
can and just be you know be available to
be do whatever I can today to help the
process of making this video cool and
and have fun and just have fun man I get
to be in a freaking country music video
dude Brooks & Dunn I listen to Clay
Walker
Garth had got kind of going on his way
then sometimes some George Strait will
pop in a little bit of shiny eye a swine
boy that's an EIU but anyhow so here I
am this weekend this week it's [ __ ]
Monday Thank You patreon for your love
and your support through you guys I'm
able to do a lot of nice stuff and so
I'm very grateful so I just got picked
up in the this is the bishop Gunn actual
tour van right here dude let me tell you
brah good this is not smell good and
that's burn sharp their drummer look at
this fan though this thing is chicken
fried pork skins yeah you can't mix
chicken import dude come on boy that's
the dark arts a lock this you know don't
even have a regular lock on it bro they
gotta hook this thing on the outside cam
an oh but you got to get both doors bro
you can't leave that passenger side
[ __ ] I'll be air tow baby and these
dudes out here y'all must be on that
dust at night bro y'all got them hitters
like that boy right here riding in the
dang dander out here it's a good place
to [ __ ] fry up a fox out here
Vernell sharp that's a drummer right
there
how many drumsticks to use these two
through yourself really right now do you
use what do you put one in each hand I
like to do one of my left between my
knuckles right here are you serious no
dude if you hit three hands how good of
a drummer will you be a lot better
that's a hitter right there that Bishop
gun Natchez boy Church fan boy yeah this
is I don't know what church this is
Amboy this seemed I guess smell like
sacrilege bro do you have any dirty
blankets they got in here how many
straight up but ghosts or [ __ ] flying
around in this sucker yeah man is it a
fourth row yeah what happened to that
fourth row mr. Shore I started a couple
small business operator
the fact that we even had to make it
soaked back there what song are we gonna
work on today burn Alabama so this is
the church right here where we gonna
shoot
[Music]
and an accident
so this is where we take today and here
in this church right here where the Lord
lives at and they got these benches
right here you could sit in you could
sleep too if you want are you supposed
to stay up because the Lord likes it if
you awake so that's how he works you
can't work if you rest and really look
at that light mustache coming in boy
look at that sunlight on that [ __ ]
lip hair boy broke down out of truck
stop she looked about it as a story she
came for right here for the chain for
changing and everything as the camper
there's my beautiful sidekick co-star
today say hello hi guys I'm Alex that's
Alex
and she is playing what are you playing
today Alex I am playing I don't know if
I'm your girlfriend I don't know I'm
just like kind of brought you to a very
corrupt place like a lovebird yeah I'm
seduced you I'm like a siren okay so
this is my suit actually I got that
adult man suit boy right there boy
local hitchhiker right there probably so
we're shooting this other scene back
here about this Creek today because I
got to get teamed up you know not autism
baptism you know and it's one or the
other sometimes in the world and
sometimes you can get both but I'm not
here today I'm out here doing real life
baptism [ __ ] today boy Chisolm gang bro
just my favorite hair right here hang up
my favorite hair
[Applause]
we'll have dark roots session and order
certainly redo it seemed like she was
so we've been shooting today and that's
Megan right there we are out here on
this farm out here and it's nice and we
got maybe a couple more shots and then
we're done with the first day today
how's the first day been Megan it's been
so good well there's been good now about
to get creepy into the night
[ __ ] she says she's like a little
bit of a knight get daddy got that goat
mask huh and he got that hitter too I
think I've been parking lot goat ladies
right there boy a couple of years a
couple of brisket sisters right there
Oh
look spooky huh we looking spooky out
here boy I'm a nest spooky we in that
spooky Club how's it been as he likes me
you guys have been gathering some steam
recently what does that feel like for
you surprising some tense satisfying fun
yeah and tell me like the like from like
the first shows when you guys are going
out to now do you are you do you feel a
difference out there yeah because crowds
were more than tension aliy there yeah
rather than you know playing somewhere
where people hang out right what are
these band mates like if somebody's got
some little CD to me see yeah fine it
just seems like you know look at some of
these guys and it's like come on man and
we just have for Travis's and here's how
I don't know if I could put up with that
really would you guys get along for
Travis's no if you have to put them in
their place if there had to be four of
one band member who do you think it
would be best Travis is our director
right here
Tyler Barksdale going on one of the best
to hard work are really creative
accurate on what he wants so I kind of
want to watch it to see what happens
once it's all done yeah I basically know
that the rundown
it's got a few surprises in there yeah
it's gonna be entertaining to me to
watch the first time we put a hundred
percent faith into Tyler Martindale so
don't screw it up Tyler
yeah Tyler that's on you boy Larry right
there brother
there you go boy I had a vial thirty you
thank you a lovely but a strange
situation she was quick to change the
station window
[Music]
well thanks for watching that video
right there that was a beautiful little
segment I think
but of course I'm partisan to myself but
you can move on to another video right
now you can check on this video or on
this video that's two different options
and you can also subscribe to the
channel check on a new video subscribe
to the channel check subscribe subscribe